here are three reasons removing
president Donald Trump from Colorado
ballots won't make things better as
recent Eric Bame reports the Colorado
supreme court ordered president Trump be
removed from the state's Republican
primary ballot they cite the 14th
Amendment which prohibits former
officials who have engaged in
Insurrection from holding office first
Trump hasn't been convicted of any
crimes related to January 6th or his
attempts to overturn the election he
currently has two election interference
cases brought against him but innocent
until proven guilty second Trump's
critics say he represents a threat to
democracy but removing someone from the
ballot to save democracy is a weird
argument at best and a rather
authoritarian one at the worst finally
taking Trump off the ballot in blue
States probably won't change outcomes
but it could give Republicans a
legitimate and permanent grievance
Democrats and some Republicans Will hail
this ruling as a win but it seems
Colorado Supreme Court will make things
worse not better